céréales quand c'était quand c'est ton
appart l'appartement de la famille
Bourdeau n'est plus du tout ce qu'il
était partout il y a des traces une
scène de désolation attendait Franck
Bourdeau des murs ravagés le plafond a
fessé de l'eau un peu partout
on vient de monter en fait tout est tout
est détruit l'appartement l'appartement
escrable le plafond c'était fondré mais
on a réussi à sortir quand même des des
trucs de notre appartement qui sont
surprend on est un peu surpris il a eu
quelques minutes seulement pour
rattraper des effets personnels ces
guitare et de précieuses photos de
famille notamment l'essentiel en
attendant de connaître la suite comme
lui quel que soit centre résidents ont
pu entrer à l'intérieur accompagné des
pompiers ils devront être relogés et
toute notre vie là-dedans on est parti
tellement vite tout est tombé le dubroc
est tombé l'isolation est tombée il y a
plus rien on trouvera pas d'autres
logements faciles et puis avec la pièce
de Airbnb à Montréal Maintenant essayons
tout un logement
il aura fallu plus de 42 heures de
travail et 150 pompiers pour venir à
bout du brasier finalement maîtrisé
samedi matin un travail colossal pour
tenter de sauver l'immeuble patrimonial
qui abritait aussi une importance salle
de spectacle
pour les jeunes les jeunes en début de
carrière on peut de salles
accessibles comme la chapelle des
cerises du Bon Pasteur il faut
absolument que la chapelle maintienne sa
mission ça vocation un clavecin un vieux
de 250 ans a pu être épargné
heureusement il était bien protégé en
fait on a eu la chance jeudi
le clavecin n'était pas sur la scène
principale de la chapelle il était dans
une salle derrière plus de 48 heures
après
l'incendie l'enquête pour faire la
lumière sur les événements doit débuter
lundi ici qui me permettra au Canada
Montréal